Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Jack White
Boca Es
Excellent
Kein ASMR Stream hier
Alles Hyper Agile, diagonal skaliert
Stand Up, Chat, Daily Scrum, auf geht's, das habt ihr heute gemacht
Nächste Sprintplanung steht an
Jeder einmal schnell, jeder hat 30 Sekunden Zeit
Spaß mit SVG
Spaß mit SVG, ich weiß nicht ob das Spaß ist
Wie sprechen die coolen Leute eigentlich SVG aus? SVG oder Spaß mit SVGs?
SVG´s okay ah guck mal da wir haben ja sogar mittlerweile
ein exquisite sellout link so muss das sein
Spaß mit Jarzons
ne das kannst du damit machen aber ich installiere
keinen wobei vielleicht ist er nicht sogar ein homosystem os das probieren
könnte man theoretisch sogar mal ausprobieren
so als erstes muss ich meinen sd kartenleser suchen muss man sd kartenleser
fällt mir gerade auf excellent wo habe ich den wieder hin
ja usb multimeter brauchen wir nicht
sparkassen online banking karte brauchen wir nicht
usb sticks brauchen wir nicht schraubendreher brauchen wir nicht
wo ist mein wo ist mein micro sd karten reader oder generell meinen sd karten reader den
brauchen wir jetzt
da excellent ich habe ihn gefunden
wir arbeiten tatsächlich agil mit scrum und hatten heute daily
ja ich hatte auch schon mal scrum daily scrum zweimal die woche
man man man stellt fest die benahmung passt nicht so ganz
wie kann ein daily scrum zweimal die woche sein das kommt daher wenn man die
sachen so nennt weil man geil sein will aber man ist nicht geil genug um
komplett agil zu sein ja bei uns war daily scrum zweimal die
woche das klingt bescheuert aber war so
l2p trime gaming was war das prime gaming ich kann hier nicht sprechen
danke schön für den sub
nein keine mario kart musik heute please
besser
a white pepo blanket wobei moment das ist das ist normal people blanket ich habe gar
kein white pepo blanket was ist denn hier los
ich habe nur
white pepo pfeil herz
zweimal die woche scrum werden sich nicht durchsetzen
ja wir hatten ja auch was was ich auch was ich auch witzig fand wir waren ja
schon agil
quasi damals also zu zeiten wo ich die ausbildung gemacht hat
er gemacht habe die wollten auch schon agil sein das waren so das sind die
ersten auf keimungen auf keine gekeimten sachen von agil
und
da haben wir auch immer daily scrum gemacht
und daily scrum war im prinzip nicht das was man sich darunter vorstellt
sondern
wir standen alle da durften uns nicht hin durften uns nicht hinsetzen
und jeder hat runter gerattert was er gemacht hat was er vor hat zu machen
und es ging im prinzip da nicht drum eine update stand zu geben sondern
um zu zeigen
jemand der viel labert macht angeblich auch viel
was dann was da natürlich total ausgeartet ist
so ein daily scrum ist normalerweise viertel stunde je nachdem
aber bei uns ging es dann teilweise eine stunde oder so wenn viel zu labern war
daily das war der komplette witz
das war null mit dem zu tun gehabt wie es eigentlich gedacht war
rusty dankeschön für den sub exquisite exquisite
und bei der wei
nicht florana
flor walker
jetzt habe ich euch ja erzählt dass wir bei uns auf die klorreiche idee gekommen
sind also für alle die nicht dabei war das wollte ich schon mal schnell erzählen weil so ein ultra geiles
wort gewesen ist
ähm
sie haben letztens irgendwelche
stromausfall test gemacht
und da hab ich halt
gemeint hey das könnte problematisch sein
wo alle hoffen wenn jetzt gerade wenn alle home office machen und der
stromausfall test dauert so lange und die notebook batterien halten nicht durch
also sprich es könnte durchaus sein dass die leute montags nicht arbeiten können
weil alle notebooks übers wochenende ausgegangen sind
so und da war die antwort darauf von den koordinator koordinatorin
ja das wenn das passieren sollte
dann setzen wir einen flor walker ein
man konnte es nicht man konnte es nicht so nennen
man konnte nicht einfach sagen okay dann schicken wir jemand rum
wir schicken jemand rum der die notebooks wieder einschalten was übrigens
bei mehreren etagen und hunderten mit der spiegel egal
nein das war ein flor walker
das hat mich sofort an den day walker erinnert
das ist quasi
weiß ich ob das damit was zu tun hat
ja die könnte mit e-scootern rumfahren das wäre doch noch was
weißt du was ein web gis ist oder an web web gis
ein was
das ist
geodatenspezifische
ein web gis
ein web schiss
ähm
ein web schiss könnte sein wenn man auf dem klo ist mit seinem handy und dabei im
internet was guckt
möglich möglich
so chat
schreibt ruhig weiter in chat ich guck gleich
ich flesch nebenbei mal kurz
den raspberry pi
weil ansonsten dauert das wieder so lang
mal kurz fünf monat angeste für den sub
poggers subscription
ich starte nur für dich die poggers vm
link vorschau geht nicht
und wie läufts bei jetzt ja schon ein paar neue am start
also es haben es haben wohl einige gemacht ja ja ich hab jetzt aber nur so
zwischenstand vom wochenden ich weiß nicht wie viele leute sich schon
angemeldet haben
ehrlich gesagt ich bin es jetzt auch nicht so wichtig
hauptsache es war genug
dass alles damit zufrieden sind ja
was habe ich gestern noch mal bei amazon den wahren korb ich hab nämlich auch
nichts bestellt
aber den ganzen kram ok exquisite
aber ich war mal kurz hier browser zu browser browser weg
leute gibt euch den ruck
eins ab noch um den scam train zu vollenden
lasst euch mal richtig schön das geld von twitch aus der tasche ziehen dann
habe ich wenigstens was von ja
guck mal ihr habt die auswahl ihr könnt es bei irgendwelchen pool grills
spenden
und dann schreiben die sich euren namen aufs bein
oder ihr könnt es bei mir spenden und ich mach nix und behalte das geld einfach
lord emperator twitch prime dankeschön für den sub
kengin hat auch gesagt und hat ein und hat eben die brithil
scheiß ob ich das richtig ausgesprochen hab 95 abo geschenkt dankeschön für die subs leute
ups falscher knopf
huge big brain subscription
foggets auch
dankeschön für den sub
guck mal gleich haben sogar stufe 2 hype train geschafft
flutscht ja heute
besser als bei pool streams
bei pool streams siehts immer nur so aus als wirds flutschen aber es darf nicht flutschen
weil das gegen tos ist
also
erst mal kurz aktuelles raspian download was hier übrigens gar nicht mehr
raspian heißt sondern
raspberry pi os
gibt es das eigentlich schon direkt als download als 64 bit variante
übrigens ich hab dann how to gefunden vielleicht
leute ich erzähl vielleicht erst mal kurz was ich heute machen will
bevor ich anfange bevor ich anfange dauernd zu laufen also
mach mal ihk aufgaben
wenn du ihk aufgaben findest
die eh copyright free sind oder du die oder du die so entfremdest
dass sie nichts mehr mit der eigentlichen ihk sache zu tun haben und ich
da copyright technisch raus bin
und du dran schuld bist
dann mache ich das auch aber ich werde mir keine prüfung im stream runterladen und danach
eh monka tos
genau das ist die frage theoretisch schon
ich hab nämlich vorhin einen guide gefunden
das wirst du mal ausprobieren ich bin selbst gespannt
ich habe heute morgen im discord
eine schöne aufgabe gelesen
falls irgendjemand im discord ist
das bild mit den subnet masks und den multicast ips hat
könnt ihr mal einen link posten in den chat dann kann ich nämlich was zu sagen
das dürfte nicht tost genug sein weil es ja komplett unabhängig von der
lösung ist
ich glaube die war von dir
also gibt es das schon als vielen sehr spitt
zu bando moment ich wusste es gar nicht dauernd leute keck weight ich muss es nicht dauernd
ich hab doch
was jetzt
aber was ist was ist was was ist denn mit meinem teamarkt los
warum ist das grün auf einmal
muss die konfektion warum muss ich die konfektion passen
warum warum warum warum warum outdated warum die prägen die laufen
irgendwelche konfektion
die war das letzte mal auch noch schwarz
das letzte letzten stream ihr wisst genau
war meine
unten meine meine
nachbar oder was das da ist im team war noch schwarz
jetzt ist es grün
also quasi von zu lull zu pepega
jetzt haben leute ihr bilder gepostet
ne ne ne das meine ich nicht
das bild dazu
da gab es doch was mit multicast drin stand
so also was muss ich jetzt machen wie wie wie funktioniert es jetzt überhaupt
status bg default
kann ich einfach sagen bleck
gereicht das
ach du kacke
aber was weiß ich ich will es nicht in grün haben
hör mal auf das ist ja eklig
teamarkt dot files
github einfach abgucken
du musst status ok ich ich vertraue dem chat ich vertraue ich ich vertraue dem
chat
chat ich vertraue euch mal gucken ob das ob das gerechtfertigt ist
status style muss ich mal also was auch set g
status style bg default
ripp geht nicht
jebaited
kampfkehren ansatz ist abgegiftet dankeschön
ok wie wie stelle ich das leute bevor ich
bevor ich jetzt die die geschichte respite ich muss die grüne leiste da unten weg
bekommen sonst kriege ich anfälle
teamarks set
background color
so und das ist jetzt irgendwas von von letztem letzten monat
ja transparent ist auch ok
set status
kacke
das habe ich doch
hier ist von 2014 das funktioniert nicht
warum geht es nicht
wie kriege ich diese grüne leiste wie kriege ich die grüne leiste
vor allem warum warum machen die an den settings so viel
set g status bg plakt das habe ich doch schon ausprobiert das funktioniert
nicht
das geht nicht
also
das muss rauskriegen
setz teamarks background background
ja letztes jahr
ja das geht ja gar nicht
du musst erst alles offene sessions zumachen naja wird es ist die einzig
offene
ist es die einzig offene session
akak weight
ich hatte noch eine session auf
ich hab
warum hab wo kommt der bitteschön die session her ich hab die vm gerade neu
gestartet
und eine session
vor allem ich habe eine session die sich automatisch neu startet guck mal was ich
hier alles hab
warum habe ich denn sowas
das habe ich da gemacht
jene teamarks session die sich automatisch startet ok egal wunderbar so ist perfekt
jetzt können wir das so lassen
der chat weiß es wieder
der chat chat chat wusste schon wieder von Anfang an
also
wie hieß dieser raspberry pi imager
image
imager hier da ist er
imager
und wie hieß die
ras
wie heißt dann dieses kackprogramm imager
rpi imager
meine güte da sollste mal drauf kommen
gibt es da gibt es da schon 64 64 spitz debian
raspberry pi os 23 spit
raspberry pi os
osa
auch nicht
ok dann muss ich mal in den guide gucken ich habe nämlich einen guide gefunden dazu
wie das ganze funktioniert
der ist von vor fünf monaten das heißt er sollte
relativ aktuell sein und angeblich
kann man dort
das so umstellen dass man kvm verwenden kann
auf dem raspberry pi mit mit raspian oder oder raspberry pi os
also
things you will need
haben wir
haben wir haben wir
haben wir haben wir haben monitor in den monitor brauche ich es ist hart zugang
beste
vor jecane kvm mit mir die 2 f kvm an all required tools in
wat moment
fedora
jebaited
was ist fedora
will es nicht mit fedora machen ich glaube es geht los
bei 4 kvm
abt
ich habe aber ein guide gesehen der das mit raspberry pi os gemacht hat
excellent guck mal da
ja da haben wir es doch also
also was müssen wir machen
wir machen heute tutorial hero wir basteln das anhand des tutorials einfach mal
nach
also haben wir haben wir haben wir
how to install raspberry pi imager weiß ich
before enabling 64bitkern installing kvm
to upgrade all existing packages ok das machen wir also der installiert
standardmäßig default raspberry pi
os und dann
und wo ab und wie macht man den 64bitkernel an
full upgrade ja alles klar gut
wo macht man braucht auf jeden fall 64bit sonst gehts net das weiß ich
hier enabling 64bitkernel
so ist das ja das ist
64bitkernel on raspberry pi os open the cmd kasse nano
die noobs wieder die noobs
die noobs fliegen den raspberry pi
nano
also niemand der auch nur im ansatz
die agilität besitzt um sowas zu machen würde nano verwenden
windows admins verwenden nano
richtig echte hacker man's vim only
die i only seht only
seht auch nie machen richtige hacker
also
justin sich pittkorn
und was muss man dann da reinschreiben
abends in sich spitt eins
alles klar
also ich habe hier den
Dings Leser Kartenleser und jetzt brauche ich mal eine SD Karte vom Raspberry Pi
SD Karte vom Raspberry Pi zack
64 also ich habe eine ich habe wer sich weil die frage immer kommt nicht zeigt am Anfang noch mal also was ich was meine absolut Lieblings
SD Karten sind für den Raspberry Pi ist
Samsung Pro Endurance und dann die die es gerade gibt und günstig sind
Mir ist noch nie eine davon kaputt gegangen
Das ist by the way viel zu viel zu teuer
Aber die sind echt poggers
So also dann
Machen wir das mal
Ich mache mal kurz das Zeug in micro SD also in den Kartenleser rein
Jetzt muss ich gerade mal gucken welches Kabel ich raus machen kann
Was ist mein Mikrofon das da
Raus machen okay
Hallo SD Kartenleser gehste rein
Jawoll
Geh fort
Wo ist der SD Kartenleser
Warum kein Ubuntu Server
Warum kein Fedora
Warum kein Arch
Warum kein Gentoo
Das ist eine gute Frage hier im Chat
Kann man konnte man da nicht ja eigentlich hoch
Also du kannst auch irgendwelche billige SD Karten nehmen
Aber die gehen halt relativ schnell kaputt
Gerade wenn du diese diese 2 Euro 50 Kingston 8 Gigabyte nimmst oder so
Die gehen relativ schnell kaputt
Der Raspberry Pi hat einen Hang dazu
Gerade wenn er ohne also wenn der Strom einfach ausgeschaltet wird kaputt zu gehen
Also nicht unwiederbringlich kaputt
Aber der Raspberry Pi hat ja so eine komische Geschichte mit Firmware
Also proprietäre Firmware Teile quasi auf der SD Karte und Bios und so
Das ist ganz merkwürdige Geschichte
Und wenn da an dem falschen Sektor was kaputt geht butet das Ding nicht mehr
Aber was
Haben dazu gerade rausgebracht KVM haben einen zusammengebaut für 100 bis 300
Die sonst 8 je nach Stufe und Features Kosten zusammengebaut
Das ist umsonst für einen Entwickler
Zeigt mal schickt mal Link
Schickt mal Blitz Link
Können wir uns gleich angucken
So und irgendjemand hat vorhin hat hier die IHK Fragen gepostet oder war das das hier
Da kann ich das aufmachen Leute ok
Oh je Ach du Scheiße
Ja das kann ich zeigen das ist kein Monka Toss das ist ok
Aber wie heißt dieser Channel
Ach ich weiß wieder
Welcher Channel das war
Das waren die mit dem
Mit diesem Router mit
Riesen Grafana Dashboard
Wo Leute im Chat gesagt haben das wäre MegaPainsChamp und ich fand das Video eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht
Und aber auf der anderen Seite die hatten auch mal ein Video mit irgendeinem
Komischen Windows Tuning Pack was ich überhaupt nicht gut fand
KVM Moment Moment das meine ich nicht mit KVM
Das meine ich nicht mit KVM
Das ist ein Keyboard Switch
Ich meine mit KVM die Virtualisierung Technik vielleicht sollte ich vielleicht sollte ich das eigentlich vielleicht sollte ich das noch mal einen Titel schreiben
Wobei ne ich muss da KVM reinschreiben was soll ich sonst da steht Virtualisierung KVM im Titel
So und wo war die Frage dazu von der Prüfung
Ja also exzellent IHK Prüfung Leute
Ja so ist so ist das ok also so ist das denke ich kein Monka Toss wenn mich das einer fragt
Also was für die Vila für die VLANs
Ich will halt mal auf ich bin jetzt eigentlich kein IHK ok ok ok
Exzellent ich kann das nicht ich versage da jetzt voll sage ich euch
Also für die VLANs sollte Adressbereich 121681.slash24 mit der Subnet
Wait a minute
Slash 24 ist doch schon die Subnet Maske und
Also das ist halt definitiv nicht Slash 24 ach jetzt weiß ich was die wollen
Jetzt weiß ich was die wollen jetzt habe ich verstanden
Die wollen die wollen du bekommst diesen Adressbereich zugeteilt und du sollst daraus zwei Netze machen
Also du sollst quasi das da machen
Also nicht diesen komischen Wein sondern
Das sollst du machen oder wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe ich glaube das ich glaube
das sollst du machen in der Frage
Nee eigentlich waren wir keine IHK Prüfung es hat gerade einer was geschickt
Nennen sie zwei Gründe für die Wahl dieses Adressbereichs
Ok Leute ich muss mal kurz 14 Jahre zurück im Kopf was würde ich da hinschreiben
Es ist ein privater Adressbereich das heißt ich kann mich da austoben wie ich will
Das ist vielleicht ein Grund
Es wird oft verwendet man kann sich gut merken
Es wird nicht im Internet geroutet
Ich weiß aber nicht ob das ein guter Grund ist
Das reicht oder reicht das
Vielleicht kennt ihr auch irgendjemand die Muster antworten dafür
Keine Ahnung ok
Ermitteln sie Anzahl der Subnetze die mit der Subnetmaske eingerichtet werden können
Da habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf
Da habe ich jetzt keinen Nerv drauf
Also das müsste dann im Endeffekt
Es ist dann 23
Wisst ihr was ich einfach mache
Wisst ihr was ich mache
Ich mache easymode
Moment was brauchen wir für ein Subnetmaske
Was wollen die haben
Naja exquisite und da habe ich es doch
Also das ist ein Slash 27
Ach warum 23
Ich muss natürlich höher gehen
Das ist ja Blödsinn
Also das ist ein Slash 27
Das heißt ich kann einmal von 1 bis 30
Und dann einmal von 33 bis 62 oder so
Das ist aber ultra bescheuert geschrieben
Was wollen die eigentlich von mir jetzt
Die wollen dass ich quasi mehrere Netze da draus mache
Also die antwort ist quasi im Endeffekt
Dass ich 4 oder 5 oder wie immer da rein passen
Slash 27 da angebe
Also die wollen quasi dass ich einmal
Schreibe das hier
1 bis 30
Und dann wollen sie dass ich schreibe
33 bis 62
65 bis 94
Oder das wollen sie da als antwort oder
Ach ne die anzahl der Subnetze die damit eingedingst werden kann
Wie viel sind denn das
Kann man ja ausprobieren
Ja, müssten 8 dann sein
Ok also 8 ist die richtige antwort hier unten dann
Ok alles klar ok
Also 8, 8 und die 2 Gründe haben wir auch
Wie kommt man auf 8 naja man kann das
Du könntest das einfach durchzählen
Ich meine also ich vermute mal dass es 8 sind
Ich habe es jetzt nicht genau nachgerechnet
Du kriegst du kriegst 30 Hosts glaube ich in ein Netz
Du kriegst 30 Hosts in ein Netz
Also du kriegst 30
Also 3
Dann kriegst du 120 sind 4
Dann kriegst du 150 sind 5
Dann kriegst du 180 sind 6
Dann kriegst du 210 sind 7
Und dann kriegst du 240
Dann kriegst du 240 sind 8
Egal ich bin mir relativ sicher es sind 8
Auf der anderen Seite du könntest es auch so machen
Moment ich habe noch eine bessere Idee
Du hast ja diesen Netzbereich
So dieser Netzbereich sind
Hier eins in Subnet Mask
Und hier 0
So und wir wissen jetzt es ist ein Slash 27
Und ein Slash 27 sind die ersten 3 Bits
Von dem letzten Octet
Kriegst du für deine für deinen
Stellskram
So und das sind dann 2 hoch 3
Und 2 hoch 3 sind 8
So ich hoffe ich bin in der ERK Prüfung nicht durchgefallen jetzt
Okay also was haben wir als nächstes
Nennen sie in folgende Tabelle für die IP Adressklassen B, C und D
Die jeweiligen Standards Abnetze
Das weiß ich total aus dem Kopf
Okay okay okay
C ist Slash 24
C ist 1
Okay Moment Leute ob ich das aus dem Kopf zusammenkriege
Okay nichts sagen nicht spoilern Chat
Halte die ruhig kein Backseat
Also kein Backseat stellt
Also C ist doch glaube ich
1 2 1 6 8 0 Punkt 0 bis
Bis da ne
Oder
Das weiß ich doch aus dem Kopf nicht
Alter das benutzt doch auch kein Mensch mehr
So A ist glaube ich 10 Punkt 0 Punkt 0 bis
Bis 255
Okay wir machen jetzt einfach mal so
Und das andere ist warte mal 1 7 2 2 7 ne
1 7 2 2 7
0 0
War das B
Alter das ist Jahre her
Okay und das dann bis bis
205 255
Das heißt das ist ein Slash 16
Das ist ein Slash 8
Und das ist ein Slash 14
Ne
Doch
Oder?
Ne
Wait a minute
Wartet mal
Ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne
Warte mal das stimmt nicht
Das stimmt nicht was ich da gemacht hab
Das stimmt
Warte mal
Das ist auch ein Slash 16
Das stimmt nicht
Das hier stimmt nicht
Was weiß ich denn
Okay
Mal gucken wieviel davon denn stimmt was ich erzählt hab
Slash 12 war das meine Güte
Das weiß ich doch nicht aus dem Kopf
Was
Nie im Leben Fake News
Das stimmt nicht
Was
Hä
Das stimmt doch
Das war doch da
Das ich hab recht
Ich hab recht das stimmt nicht
Ja hier ist doch
Soll ich doch
Hier
Das ist aber was anderes ne
Okay es ist ein Slash 12
Also das stimmt schon mal was ich hier gemacht hab
Außer das da
Das ist 17227
Das ist 16 bis 31
Okay
Klasse A
Klasse B
Klasse C
Siehst du mal
Ich hab doch recht
So
Also zumindest so halbwegs
So und was wollen die da jetzt wissen
Klasse D
Achso ja das hab ich heut morgen ja schon nachgeguckt
Klasse D ist Multicast
Das hätt ich aber so aus dem Kopf nicht gewusst ne
Das weiß ich nur weil ich heut morgen nachgeguckt hab
Ach du Scheiße was fragen ey
Darf man mittlerweile dieses komische Buch noch verwenden
Darf man das Buch noch verwenden da steht das bestimmt drinne
Schon seit Jahren nicht mehr
Ach du Scheiße ey
Okay ja das hätt ich voll verkackt
Warum ist das hier überhaupt durchgestrichen
Meine Güte ey ihr Karstels
Painz Champ
So und Subnet Maske für Multicasts
Also von wo bis wo geht Multicast
Multicast geht von was
244 bis
Das war ein Slash 4 ne
Slash 4 ja
Also die Subnet Maske wenn man die irgendwie in irgendeiner
Eid und Weise bei Multicast angeben möchte
Wäre das ein Slash 4
Was aber ehrlich gesagt wenig Sinn ergibt
Okay was auch immer
Ich mach das jetzt einfach mal zu und ignorier das jetzt dass ich das heute gesehen hab
Okay also jetzt können wir endlich das Raspberry Pi Image machen
Ups choose OS Raspberry Pi OS choose Storage 64G
Right yes
Seid froh dass sie euch das nicht mit IPv6 machen lassen
Leute wer kennt die Regeln wie man eine IPv6 Adresse abkürzen darf
Jetzt mal ernsthaft wer kennt die aus dem Kopf
Wie darf man
Hab ich hier überhaupt irgendwie eine
Na hier ist ja schon die GT schon gekürzt
Nullen weglassen ja aber Null Blöcke kann man auch nicht
Ja ja das geht aber aber die Null Blöcke darf man nur beim ersten Mal weglassen oder
war das nicht so
Es gibt es gibt es gibt eine Sache die darf man im IPv6 Adress nur einmal weglassen
Genau man darf den größten Null Block mit Doppelpunkt Doppelpunkt genau
Meine Güte heute ist immer richtig Hacker Modus angesagt wieder
Verpassende Atmosphäre schaffen Ich bin aber schon begeistert dass der Chat
da sieht man mal dass die ganzen Subs was gebracht haben dass der Chat sowas weist
Ich hab den einzigen Chat auf ganz Twitch der sowas weist wollen wir wetten
Wollen wir wetten ich hab den einzigen Chat der sowas weist
Massive IQ Chat
Herren IQ Ich hab das alle aber unabhängig voneinander
geschrieben also ist wirklich Biggest Biggest Hive Mind hier
G-Styles hat Subscribed vor 10 Monaten hab ich nicht gesehen Dankeschön für den Sub
Massive Huge Poggers Subscription
TruffilaX hat abonniert vor 15 Minuten hab ich auch nicht gesehen Dankeschön für den
Sub
Guck mal ob ich auch was übersehen hab ne zum Glück nicht
Schlautblin Lord Imperator vor der halben Stunde hab ich übersehen Dankeschön für
den Prime Sub
So haben wir es heute noch mal mit Flaschen
Du verwendest ja TV Headends ja
O-Joy XO4 oder Raspberry für T-Verhältnisse
Was genau hat Zigbee to MQTD mit TV Headends zu tun
Oder ist es jetzt alles nichts miteinander zu tun und du willst es da einfach noch drauf
passen
Also ich hab den ja ich hab ja den weil da kannst du gleich ne Festplatte reinstecken
Äh nicht H2 im Moment HC, HC2 hab ich
Das ist so ein Kleiner da kannst du gleich direkt ne Festplatte reinstecken das ist ganz
praktisch
Ich hoffe Leute ihr steckt auch gerne Festplatten rein
In den Anschluss also in Zata Port natürlich
So verifying
Raspberry Pi 3B als Nass in dem Nähe
Der Raspberry Pi ist kein gutes Nass auch der Vierer nicht
Bei den Alten ist die Anbindung viel zu lahm und bei den Neuen hat die ja immer noch keine
Krypto Extension dass du es schnell, fair und schnell entschlüsseln kannst
Welche sonst, na zum Beispiel die O-Joy Dinger sind ganz gut
Wenn Gigabit reicht ohne eine Low Power Intel Plattform da geht auch deutlich mehr
So continue zack
Ok und jetzt das Allerwichtigste was ich immer vergesse und das jedes Mal neu mounten muss
Mount
Sdb Moment ist es überhaupt Sdb
Sdb ja Sdb ist es wie hieß das chat wie hieß das andere nochmal blk
Da gab es ja noch so ne viel schönere Übersicht
Tricks crazy Dankeschön für zwei Monate Subscription
Nein nein nein nicht nicht zwei Monate Moment Moment Moment Moment
Nicht zwei Monate Stufe 2 Subscription
Alter sowas haben wir ja ganz ganz selten Dankeschön für huge massive poggers stonks
Subscription hier
Das ist ja schon ein Hyper Subscription wert hier
Ich hab leider keine extra Emotes für Tier 2 und Tier 3 Subscription
Übrigens nur die normalen Emotes Subscriben so wenig Leute ich hab mir da bisher noch keine
Gedanken drüber gemacht aber ich hab ja eh noch 10 Emote Slots offen vielleicht soll
ich die mal füllen
Da muss der Chainlord muss wieder Emotes craften
Leute wisst ihr was ich mich ernsthaft frage
Wann bringt Twitch GIF Emotes jetzt ernsthaft
Habt ihr ne Idee warum hat Twitch noch keine GIF Emotes gemacht
Right kill Stufe 1 Dankeschön für den Sub
Ich vermute mal weil die Leute die gleich wieder für irgendwelche anstößigen Dinger verwenden
würden
Aber auf der anderen Seite könnte man das mit normalen Emotes auch
Speicherplatz Pff nee glaube ich nicht dass Twitch da grad bei Amazon Probleme hat
Hast du Snap in deiner VM ja leider
Melcrypto Dankeschön zwei Monate danke für den Sub
Right kill auch danke für den Sub
Amatera
The Tricks hat was geschrieben Gängeschön Zuschauer seit 10 Jahren exquisite
Schön dass du ein W her gefunden hast
Off Topic Frage Was sind deine Empfehlungen Niedungssorfer abzusichern
Das erste was du machst ist du gehst drauf und sagst FW hab ich jetzt nicht entzählt
UFW Allow SSH und danach sagst du UFW Default Deny und danach sagst du UFW Enable
Das ist das erste was du machst und dann ist erstmal gut
Das reicht erstmal das ist das wichtigste was du machen musst
So und dann schaltest du SSH noch ab dass du dich per Passwort ein genau Serious Max
Das wollte ich grad sagen du schaltest danach noch ab dass du dich per Passwort einloggen
kannst
Per SSH und machst Key-Authentifizierung und das reicht
Ja UFW zum Beispiel UFW kannst du gut verwenden
So ich kann jetzt leider kein UFW zeigen weil ich hier keine Ubuntu Kiste hab noch keine
Debian Kiste
Wie weit bist du mit dem Raspberry Pi KVM Projekt
Wir haben gerade die Micro SD Karte geflasht Übrigens ich baue keine KVM ich teste ob
die Virtualisierung mit KVM geht
Vielleicht ich muss das ich muss das irgendwie ein Titel anders schreiben
Die Leute glauben die glauben ich baue irgendwelche Tastatur-Switches oder so
Aber ich mein geht Virtualisierung KVM auf dem das ist eigentlich relativ offensichtlich
Ich mach einfach KVM raus aus dem Titel wobei warum auch nicht
Vielleicht jebait ich an einen oder anderen zu gucken
Ok also was haben wir hier SDB Mount
SDB Touch SSH wir schließen es ja über Kabel an also passt alles
So Micro SD Karte ist fertig für den Raspberry Pi
Ich stöpsel das mal ein und boot das Ding
Und dann gucken wir mal
Ich muss btw noch schnell den Switch anschalten vorher wo der dran ist
Weil sonst ist hier nichts mit
Das war auch lustig
Wir haben wir haben einen unserer ich erzähle euch das mal gerade während ich das Kabel
für den Switch suche
Wir haben einen unserer externen Services in Polen gehostet
Und die haben offizielle Sprache Englisch und Polnisch
Weiß nicht warum wir das da gehostet haben
Ihr wisst ja ich sitz dort wo auch in der Nähe der Support sitzt also wenn ich auf der
Arbeit bin
Ist ne Sache hab ich mich auch immer für eingesetzt weil ich mich da mit vielen Leuten
echt gut verstehe
Aber selbst Support machen würd ich nie das wisst ihr
Zumindest hab ich da einen Anruf mitgekriegt wo einer in Polen angerufen hat
Bei diesem Provider der das macht
Mal kurz Switch einstöpseln
Und da ist ein Switch ausgefallen es gab ne Monitoring Meldung
Und da musste der an der Hotline musste der das Wort Switch buchstabieren
Hab gesagt ja wir sind hier von von bla bla bla und bei uns ist eben wir haben ne Meldung
bekommen ist ein Switch von uns bei ihnen ausgefallen
Und was was ausgefallen eine Switch was ist eine Switch
Was ist eine Switch
Ja SWI hat das versucht auf Englisch das ist auch noch Native Speaker Englisch zum Glück
der war in USA also der kann Englisch die halt in Polen eher nicht
Und da musste das denen buchstabieren und dann haben die quasi das weitergeleitet dann
irgendjemand der dann verstanden hat erstmal um was es geht
War ganz war ganz wir ja also wie gesagt kommt es mir immer so vor als geben wir als sparen
wir an der falschen Stelle ja drücken wir es mal so aus
So Raspberry Pi im Moment ich mache ihn an
Da muss ich bei mir in den Router gucken was das Ding für den IP bekommt
Routik DHCP Server
Der Router Leute routet ihr oder routet ihr
Der CoolChamp ist am Start Der CoolChamp hat sich gerade ne neue DHCP
Adresse geholt nice
Guter Mann der CoolChamp Ich muss ja sagen ich mag den CoolChamp
Ja Raspberry Pi da isser Du magst den HeizChamp also den HeizChamp
den haben wir noch nicht Das was meine Heizung ausliest heißt noch
nicht HeizChamp Dass hab ich eigentlich versäumt
aber Übrigens weil einer gesagt hat wie man seinen Leluxserver absichern sollte eine
Sache kann ich auch empfehlen Nachdem du dich nachdem du dich einmal
gelockt hast, machst du folgendes ssh copyid gibst einmal noch das Passwort ein das hab
ich verschrieben und danach musst du nie mehr Passworte eingeben und kannst jetzt auch Passwort
Login deaktivieren. So jetzt haben wir unseren Raspberry Pi hier am Start. Broken Atomic
Mode Set ja dazu kann ich nur sagen solang es läuft ist mir das wurscht. Wir sollen
einen Full Upgrade machen schreibt er. Ich glaube es ist doch überhaupt kein Unterschied
zwischen einem Full Upgrade und einem Upgrade oder? Bei Abt Get gab es ja noch den Unterschied
zwischen Dist Upgrade und Upgrade aber ich glaube mittlerweile macht er doch alles inklusive
Colonel und Gedöns. Ja das ist gut das kannst du machen das ist sinnvoll würde ich auch
so machen. Ob sich es lohnt den SSH Server Port zu ändern kann man sich drüber streiten
es ist aber ich persönlich finde es ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt weil das erste
was du am Start hast sobald ein Server länger als 5 Minuten läuft ist erstmal die China
Chinesen Dedos und CoC Dedos Geschichten auf dem SSH Port nicht Dedos was laber ich denn
Brutforce und was dann sinnvoll ist was dann sinnvoll ist ja das ist tatsächlich cool
was dann sinnvoll ist was man auch machen kann dass man sowas wie Portknocking oder so verrückte
Sachen macht wenn man ganz ganz ganz abgedrehte Sachen möchte. Aber ganz ehrlich ich habe
auf allen meinen Servern die Fault SSH Port nur Key Authentifizierung und gut ist. Ich
habe meinem Arbeitskollegen meine Projektdoku geschickt erstmal 6 Seiten Kommentare bekommen
was ich ändern soll. Ja wenn du willst kannst du es uns auch noch zeigen ne ne besser nicht
besser nicht ich will nicht dafür verantwortlich sein wenn irgendwelche geheimen Sachen im Stream
geleakt werden. Das einzige Nicht Debate Video das ist garantiert wieder ein Rickroll Video
oder? Ist das ein Rickroll Video? Ach ne gar kein Rickroll Video. Ah ja der ist gut der
hat Ahnung der kennt sich aus. Hier Hackermans. Richtig ein richtig Hardcore Hackermann. Aller
die Musik ist schon ziemlich MonkaS gerade oder? Die ist bisschen ein bisschen sehr
nervös. Super Mario Galaxy als Dubstep Remix ne beim besten will nicht.
Das ist jetzt aber ein Rickroll oder? Ich warte auf das Rickroll Video wann kommt das
Rickroll Video? Das ist bestimmt das Rickroll Video. Ja ist es wusste ich. Wusste ich.
Wie auch immer. Wahrscheinlich heißt es 8kill aber ich finde 8k 1ll ist bestimmt näher
dran an dem wie du es dir gedacht hast. Aber Dankeschön für den Prime Subscription. Massive
Sub. IQ++ für den Chat. Was für ein Laptop hast du eigentlich gar kein? Ok jetzt ist
klar er wird nie wieder Subscriben nachdem ich seinen Namen so dämlich ausgesprochen
hab. Ist vorbei. I am Onex Dankeschön für den Prime Sub. Tolle Wimtips exquisite. Ok
wir müssen jetzt mal langsam anfangen schon 20 und 20 und wir haben nix gemacht. So erstmal
Upgrade machen. C++ ist eine nice Sprache C++ ist eines der schlechtesten Sprachen auch
wenn es Trigger Chebat Comment ist das weiß ich aber ich kann es einfach so nicht stehen
lassen C++ ist einfach einer der schlechtesten Sprachen die je erfunden wurde. Die einzige
Daseinsberechtigung die C++ hat ist Unreal Engine weil es historisch so gewachsen ist
und Microcontroller gedürnt ansonsten C++ für die Tonne. Massiver Painz Champ C++. Linux
ist nicht C++ zum Glück ist Linux nicht C++ dann wird der Linux noch mehr Ragen auf der
Mailing Liste. So also Bäm haben wir gemacht alles klar. Ja haben wir auch. Update haben
wir gemacht haben wir gemacht. Warum installiert er erstmal Chrome? Und warum will er Chrome
erstmal bescheuern? Ok. Reboot. Reboot? Ich hab da noch gar nichts gemacht. Ok wenn die
Einleitung mein Reboot mach ich Reboot. Wie kommt man auf die Idee? Das sag ich auch
schon die ganze Zeit. Ich hab keine Ahnung was mit den C++ Leuten los ist. Ich mein es
gibt jetzt ja so ne Art Modulkonzept im C++ das ist ja angeblich seit dem letzten Standard
auch drinnen aber kein Compiler kanns richtig die meisten Sachen verwenden das nicht und
in C++ hast du ja auch so richtig nen Glaubenskrieg. Du hast welche die sagen nein der aktuelle
Standard ist broken ich mach nur altes Zeug und nein das machen wir sonst nicht. Die kriegen
das nie gebacken. Die werden in 30 Jahren noch mit Header rumhantieren und sich fragen
hm warum braucht man sowas überhaupt? Andere Sprachen sind bloated wir verwenden Header
Dateien. Mal eine Frage falls das grad nicht fehlen plötzlich ich fang im September eine
Ausbildung als Physi an. Kann man sich im Vorfeld schon irgendwo irgendwas tiefer beschäftigen
damit ja es wäre sinnvoll wenn du da zu viel Zeit hast gerade guck dir doch mal an in welchem
Bereich dein zukünftiger Arbeitgeber so unterwegs ist. Vielleicht gibt es irgendwas wo du sagst
spontan das lohnt sich ansonsten gerade wenn du zumindest schon mal grob weißt was du da
machst ob eher Windows oder eher Linux ja so ein paar grobe Sachen wären schon wichtig
zu wissen dann gibt es ein paar Sachen. Linux ist C. Ein bisschen Assembler und C.
Das ist bestimmt wieder Recrawl. Das ist nice. Ja dies ist überall so ich glaub das
ist echt überall so. Hat er das angenommen? Das letzte was ich gelesen habe ist das Linus
gesagt hat kein Bock drauf. So erstmal Raspberry Pi jetzt eins neu gestartet. Da ist er. Bäm.
Ok machen wir mal weiter ihr könnt ruhig weiter fragen und Sachen in den Chat stellen
ihr kennt mich ich lese das früher oder später alles. Aber wenn ich mir gerade ein Tutorial
angucken kann sein das es ein paar Minuten dauert. Also jetzt müssen wir einen 64bit
Kernel Enable und wir machen das nicht mit Nano. Wir müssen jetzt erstmal wie hast du
Chromium auf Windows hinbekommen? Ich bin einfach hingegangen und hab mir Chromium Bild
für Windows gesucht. Nämlich die da und verändere die seitdem. Aber eigentlich total sinnlos
weiß auch nicht warum ich das mache. So also Nano nein abinstall erstmal die wichtigsten
Tools nachinstallieren. T-Max, Wim, Hardtop, D-Stats was brauchen wir sonst noch? Weiß
ich grad nicht. Nano alter hört mir auf. Nur Windows Noobs verwenden Nano. Nehmst du
eine Lippwirt? Ja muss ich. Muss ich wahrscheinlich. Dass ich das GUI verwenden kann. Die Musik.
Alter was ist mit der Musik los? Die eskaliert ja voll. NC du ja verwende ich das ist tatsächlich
ganz nice für Festplattenplätze zu gucken. Ok haben wir jetzt gemacht. So jetzt müssen
wir 64bit Kernel aktivieren. Schauen wir mal ob das funst. 64 steht da nicht drinnen.
Also arm64 end of file. Ok machen wir. Ich vertraue dem Tutorial einfach mal dass sie
da kein Scheiß bauen. Ja haben wir gemacht. Aber Moment unter all. Hab ich das unter all?
Ja hab ich. Hab ich alles klar. Darf man da ein Leerzeichen dazwischen haben? Wahrscheinlich.
So. Change to make effect reboot. Muss ich nicht noch irgendwie Krabb neu updaten oder
so dafür? Anscheinend nicht. Ok Reboot. Bam. Soll doch jeder den Editor seiner Wahl verwenden?
Sehe ich ganz genau so solang Swim ist. Ne es kann jeder verwenden was er will. Bin ja
eigentlich auch ein Verfecht davon. Es kann jeder verwenden was er will. Aber trotzdem
muss man mal sagen dass Artstilungs mit I3 plus Wim schon das beste für die Kommando
Zeile ist. Also im Prinzip lasst mal überlegen was verwende ich denn eigentlich? Ich verwende
eigentlich auf der Kommando Zeile zu 90% Wim. So. Manchmal mache ich Sachen in Visual Studio
Code direkt auf wenn ich da ein bisschen umfangreichere Sachen will aber ich mache 90% Kommando
Zeile Wim. Für die meisten anderen Sachen verwende ich mittlerweile Visual Studio Code
und für größere Sachen verwende ich die passende IDE. Sei es Goland oder Rider also
einmal für Go oder C-Sharp. Oder Visual Studio unter Windows. Ein bisschen C-Line auch. Leider
ist die Plattform IO Integration nicht so gut dass ich zum größten Teil da auch Visual
Studio Code für verwende. Warum so viele Notepad plus plus verwenden verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht. Weil gerade Plugin mäßig ist Visual Studio Code doch einfach Massive Poggers.
Ok es ist eine Elektron Anwendung die erstmal 50GB RAM braucht. Du nutzt Rider sogar unter
Windows. Äh ja würde ich wahrscheinlich auch machen wenn ich jetzt wieder Sachen unter
Windows programmieren würde. Ich mache ja unter Windows im Endeffekt kaum noch was
was das angeht. So hat er jetzt rebooted. Jawoll. So dann haben wir jetzt einen 4.6 Bitkerne.
Wir haben einen 4.6 Bitkerne würde ich. Ich interpretiere das jetzt mal so. Weil nur den
als V8 und das hat nichts mit JavaScript zu tun sondern ARM V8 gibt. Hier Arch64. Exzellent
4.6 Bitkerne. Wo ist der Unterschied zwischen VI und Vim? Wahrscheinlich bei der normalen
Installation erstmal gar keiner. Weil Vim einen Compatibility Modus hat. Also VI einen
Sim Link auf Vim im Compatibility Modus ist. Aber eigentlich ist es so. VI ist die ursprüngliche
Sache und Vim ist die weiterentwickelte Sache. So rebooted haben wir schon. Haben wir auch
schon geguckt. DevKVM should be available. Ok jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit. Wait
a minute. Es gibt tatsächlich KVM direkt. Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich nicht gedacht
dass es so einfach geht. Kann man nicht direkt Raspberry Pi OS 4.6 Bit nehmen. Ich habe dazu
kein fertiges ISO gefunden. VS Code oder VS Code. Ich verwende nur noch das offizielle
Visual Studio Code. Ich benutze Platform.io für meine ESP32 Arduino Dinger und Platform.io
braucht die offizielle Microsoft C++ Extension. Die offizielle Microsoft C++ Extension geht
nur im offiziellen Visual Studio Code. Weil die offizielle Microsoft C++ Extensions Closed
Source Komponenten aus Visual Studio verwendet die sie noch nicht freigegeben haben und dementsprechend
diese Extension nur in der offiziellen Visual Studio Code Variante funktioniert. Also haben
wir das. Install Wirt Manager. Alles klar machen wir. Bäm. Warum muss es Wirt 0 eigentlich
sein. Was gibt es denn sonst noch zur Auswahl. Wirt Wirt Null. Warum ausgerechnet Wirt Null
kann ich aber Lip Wirt installieren. Wirt D. Warum ist es Null. Das verstehe ich nicht
die Benamung von. Warte mal Info. Info ist. Ach doch. Ok es heißt aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Lip Wirt Null. Ja die werden es schon wissen. Die Debian Leute. Seht ihr übrigens wie schön
schnell diese Samsung SSD ist. Ach Quatsch. Samsung Micro SD nicht Samsung SSD. KegWade.
FH mit Raspberry Pi plus Codesys. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht was Codesys in dem Zusammenhang
ist. Was ist Codesys. Das da. Hersteller unabhängig. Oh das ist irgendeine Industriegeschichte
oder so. Ok Paynes Champ. Ich bin ja froh dass man immerhin auch so viel Platz für
einen Text Editor hat. Also ich mein da kann man bestimmt gut programmieren wenn man da
so viel Platz drin hat. Das sieht aber auch ehrlich gesagt nach Windows Only aus. Ja
für Fahrzeuge und Maschinen software sagt mir gar nichts. Haben wir es. Nein wir haben
es noch nicht installiert. Also das Tutorial ist ja wirklich für die absoluten Noobs.
Press Y und dann Press Enter. Ja das müssen wir danach machen das passt. So wenn der Kram
jetzt installiert ist bin ich mal gespannt ob man direkt eine VM anlegen kann. Was für
eine VM legen wir jetzt eigentlich an. Wir probieren. Wir machen das. Moment wer war
das vorhin im Discord der wissen wollte ob Home Assistant OS funktioniert. Ok. Geh
fort. Das wollte ich jetzt nicht aufmachen. Wir probieren Home Assistant OS aus. Ja danke
endlich und dann dank dass du wieder streamst. Pepehands was los. Ich streame übrigens
die letzten drei Tage total oft schon. So jetzt hat er den Kram installiert. Für was
nutzt du deine Pies. Für ganz viel unterschiedliches Zeug. Ich habe irgendwo mal eine Textdatei
gemacht wo das alles drin steht aber ich vergesse immer wo ich die habe. Der Chat weiß das
immer also falls der Chat jetzt zufälligerweise weiß wo ich diese Textdatei immer liegen
habe dann sage ich es dir. Ansonsten müsste ich jetzt überlegen und dann vergesse ich
wahrscheinlich die Hälfte. Also ich benutze den Raspberry Pi unten einmal an der Heizung
um von meiner Heizung per Prometos Monitoring Werte auszulesen und ihr dieses Dashboard
zu packen. Raspberry Pi Zero im Keller der macht das. Dann den Raspberry Pi Zero für
die Kamera auf der Fensterbank das Ding was ich da ganz abenteuerlich mit Heißkleber
dran gepappt habe und einen Schrumpfschlauch. Dann habe ich einen OctoPie für einen 3D Drucker.
Dann habe ich einen UniFi Controller mit meiner Kameraüberwachungssoftware drauf. Dann
habe ich den Raspberry Pi hier den wir gerade immer zum Test verwenden. Im Wohnzimmer habe
ich einen Odroid HC2 ist das sowas ähnliches. Und noch jede Menge ESP und ESP266 Mikrocontroller
lasche ich jetzt mal weg. Kann sein dass ich etwas vergessen habe. Wait a minute wir haben
ein Kommando dafür. Big Brain Mods. Wir haben ernsthaft den Kommando ne ne ne. Der Stripes
hat das jetzt quasi einfach reingeschrieben. Ja Massive guck mal hier. Also die Mods sind
schon auf Zack muss man sagen. Chat die Mods haben es verdient. Alle einmal please in den
Chat Mod check. Einmal alle Mod check. Ja für die Big Brain Mods. So ist das gut.
Sehr gut. Jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur noch der Cute Mod himself. Aber der ist zu beschäftigt
gerade mit Studium und Lehramtsgrills. So jetzt haben wir den Kram installiert und jetzt müssen
wir noch den User hinzufügen. Stand irgendwas drinnen? User hinzufügen. Machen wir. Aber
nicht als Root. Ahja. Wow. Alles klar. Reboot. Ok der Typ der Rebootet echt bei allem. Ich
mach das aber wie die Anleitung nicht das nachher irgendwas übersehen hab. So haben wir es
geschafft. Ok so ganz so schnell Reboot dann doch nicht. Ich bin echt gespannt ob das funktioniert
mit KVM direkt auf Anhieb. Ich leg erstmal ne VM an mit nichts drauf und starte die und
kurops prinzipiell starten. Dann unterlegen wir Home Assistant OS. Nichts dafür damit
was machen einfach nur gucken ob es funktioniert. So also haben wir drauf. Kann ich jetzt den
Wirt Manager starten direkt? Das muss ich doch bestimmt nicht. Das muss ich doch nicht
von Hand machen oder? Das muss ich doch nicht von Hand machen. Das wird mich sehr wundern.
Läuft läuft System CTL Status Lib Wirt D ne Moment Status is running. Cannot detect
Toast CPU Model. Joa. Da muss man mit leben. Ich würd mal sagen ziemlich. Riesen Question.
Pains Champ. Aber es ist ja auch da Lila Regenbogen Einhornpony. Alles klar also wie wärs wenn
du mal zu deinem Setup ein Video machen würdest. Du hast letztens erwähnt dass du ein ESX.
Ne ne ne ne ne ne ne. Ich verwende ein VM. Ich verwende ein VM Workstation. Nicht ESX
Workstation Pro. ESX hat damit ja nichts zu tun. Es ist beides von der gleichen Firma.
Ich würde mir gern ein ähnliches Setup aufbauen würde gerne was von den Nachteilen von deinem
Setup feststellen kannst. Und auch was du eventuell schon alles ausprobiert hast hat für dich
alles gut schlecht funktioniert. Also dazu gibt es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viel zu
sagen. Ich hab mir ne billige VM Workstation Lizenz gekauft hab VM Workstation installiert.
In VM Workstation hab ich Linux installiert. Falls du meine Linux Config haben willst kannst
du dir die auf GitHub hier angucken. Da. Alles alles drin zwar nicht top aktuell aber aktuell
genug. So. Und ansonsten musst du ehrlich gesagt gar nichts machen. Du machst VM Workstation
auf. Also hier siehst du ja jetzt VM Workstation. Startest deine Linux VM. Gehst ins Fullscreen
und dann benutzt du diese Windows Desktop Wechselfunktion. Also das was man hier verwenden
kann. Kannst du mit dem Shortcut verwenden. Control Windows Taste links und rechts. Und
dann switch ich zwischen Windows und Linux. Das ist ganz einfach. Das wars. Also das ist
im Prinzip wirklich alles. Ich kenn nur KVM als Gerät zum umschalten. KVM ist die Virtualisierungsfunktion
die in Linux eingebaut ist. So also das müssen wir wahrscheinlich nicht machen was die hier
schreiben. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Download Alpine Linux. Ne ne das machen wir
alles nicht. Ich will einfach nur Wirtmanager gucken ob es startet. Ok ich gucke einfach
mal Wirtmanager ob das jetzt startet. Achso wir müssen erstmal SSH Grafische Weiterleitung
machen. Übrigens. Das muss ich jetzt vielleicht mal erklären bevor ichs mache. Also ich hab
jetzt hier ne Raspberry Pi. Der steckt hier neben mir am Switch und ist am Strom angeschlossen
aber hat kein Monitor dran und sowas. So aber ich möchte jetzt ne GUI Applikation verwenden
auf diesem Raspberry Pi. Also was grafisches. Das geht ja nicht direkt weil ich kein Monitor
dran angeschlossen hab. Was man machen kann ist folgendes. Man geht einfach per SSH drauf
allerdings mit SSH minus Y. Und dann kann man über SSH oder minus X aber minus Y ist
das neue. Dann kann man grafische Anwendungen starten und sie weiterleiten über SSH. In
der Hoffnung dass jetzt was startet. Da isser. So. Und es geht nicht. Das liegt aber an meinem
lokalen User glaube ich dass es nicht geht. So und diese GUI Anwendung die ihr hier seht
by the way die läuft auf meinem Raspberry. Die hat nichts mit mir lokal zu tun. Ich starte
das mal kurz mit sudo. Geht nicht. Nicht in der Gruppe ich hab mich aber User Mod voll
hinzugefügt. Mal gucken ob es die Gruppe überhaupt gibt. Also les etc groups. Grup. Grup. Emu. Ja.
Warum ist die GUI nicht auf dem Haus? Das kann man auch machen. Aber ich wollte jetzt
zeigen wie man GUI weiterleitet. Ich könnte es auch auf einem Haus starten. Das ist auch
kein Problem. Das wird auch funktionieren. Die Gruppe heißt lib wird. Ne die Gruppe heißt
anscheinend nur lib wird. Ohne. Ohne D. Moment vielleicht macht er das hier unten noch. Vielleicht
macht er noch das Virtual Manager. Ach so. Ja gut das kann der jetzt nicht machen. Ok
dann füge ich es mal direkt in lib wird hinzu. User Mod. So darf ich jetzt? Ich darf. Ich
bin connected Leute. Das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht. Easy. Das ist cool. Ja aber der Chat
hat recht. Ich könnte das Programm auch bei mir starten und mich dann über ssh hinverbinden.
Ist die Performance von forever workstation besser als virtualbox? Ich würde sagen ja
aber das ist jetzt nicht der große ausschlaggebende Punkt für Forever Workstation. Also ja ich
würde schon sagen dass die Performance besser ist. Gerade die Grafik Performance ist besser.
Aber ich finde die Bedienung einfach viel angenehmer mit Forever Workstation. Was ist
der kleine Hardware Verwaltungs Server für eine Software? Moment ist das das was jemand
gerade im Chat gepostet hat was ich im Einsatz habe. Das ist das hier. Wartet mal ich zeig
es dir. Das ist total Overkill. Das ist aber die einzige Software die ich gefunden habe
die ich halbwegs gerne verwende für sowas. Demo. Launch Demo. Ach komm. So sieht es
dann aus. Da mach ich meine Hardware Teile verwalten drüber. Ich verwende übrigens
nur einen Bruchteil von dieser Software. Ich hab dann sowas drinne stehen wie titty go
board mit display fach 2. Da ich weiß wo es ist. So also gucken wir mal ob wir das
KVM anlegen können. Jo. Ok. Wie KVM ist not available. Moment. KVM ok. Echt das ist nicht
möglich. Libian. Pügel den User mal der KVM Gruppe zu. Moment. Was muss ich installieren
um KVM ok zu bekommen. Command not found.com. Cpu checker. Da wäre ich ja im Leben nicht
drauf gekommen dass ich CPU checker installieren muss. Das Ding hat kein BIOS. KVM exist can
be used. Hat er Probleme mit dem User. Ich versuch das doch mal wirklich als sudo zu
starten. Ach fuck. Moment wie ging das jetzt noch mal sudo sudo x11 weiterleitung ok monka
s sudo x forwarding. Da muss man irgendwelche Cookies kopieren oder so. Ich mein wisst ihr
was die easy Variante ist. Leute wir machen jetzt passwd für root setzen. Wir locken
das einfach als root ein und gucken was funktioniert. Was. Keg wait. Sagt bloß die Password Identifizierung
für root ist deaktiviert. SSHD config. Password. Ups. Wow wow wow wow. Monka S. Was hab ich
gemacht. Yes. Ah hier. Yes. Restart SSHD. So und jetzt müsste es eigentlich mit root
gehen. Da sind wir. So jetzt können wir gucken. Jetzt haben wir auch keine Berechtigungsprobleme
mehr. KVM ist not available. Sag mal. Natürlich ist KVM available. Er sagt doch sogar selbst
KVM ist ok. Hä. Sixhead Alter. Ok was schreibt diese was schreibt die Anleitung hier weiter.
Ach so das ist anscheinend normal das da steht KVM not available. Ja dann. Ja dann. Ja dann
dann kann ich mich auch wieder als normaler User einmelden. Wobei scheiß drauf. Jetzt
bleiben wir einfach gut. Keg wait. So wird mein Job. Also dann installieren wir den Kram
mal. Wir legen einfach eine stinknormale KVM an und gucken ob es funktioniert. Network
Boot PXE ist ok. Da müsste ich eigentlich direkt was booten können. Schauen wir mal
ob PXE Boot bei mir funktioniert mit Arm Architektur. 64 muss man da noch irgendwas umstellen.
Machinetype wird. Was jetzt anscheinend nicht. Er stellt zumindest nichts um. Ja ja ISO passt
schon. Ok. Also PXE Boot. Choose Operating System you are installing. Kann ich den Debian
oder so. Next. Memory. Wie viel hab ich denn Speicher auf meinem Raspberry Pi. Vier Gigabyte
ja 1024. Zwei CPUs. Ich meine ich lösch das Ding. Ich lösch das Ding ja eh gleich wieder
20 G. Ja ja passt alles. Forward PXE install. Does not support PXE. Ok. Gehen wir jetzt
auf das richtige Netzwerk Interface ein ETH Null. What. Es ist einfach der Wirt Manager
gecrasht. Kack wait. Warum. Noch bevor ich die VM anlegen konnte einfach. Grip. Ja das
Raspbian OS mache ich dann wenn ich weiß dass überhaupt eine VM bootet. Ok PXE. Next.
Debian. Wir machen das gleiche nochmal. Debian 10. Forward. Zwei CPUs. Jawoll. Passt. Acht
den Platz noch nicht angelegt. ETH Null. Finish. Warum eigentlich KVM auf Raspberry
Pi. Weil das eine coole Geschichte ist wenn es funktioniert. Zum Beispiel wenn man sein
Heim Automatisierungszeugs drauf laufen lassen will und noch andere Sachen auf Raspberry
Pi machen möchte. Ok. Das funktioniert anscheinend nicht. Gut da muss ich es mit nut machen
was aber für PXE nicht gehen wird. Virtual Network is not active. Would you like to start.
Yes. ESXI offen. Pi haben wir gemacht. Naja Docker geht nicht. Wenn du quasi dein System
verwenden willst was selbst sich ums Docker Management kümmert. ETH Null ist wahrscheinlich
keine Bridge. Ja aber normalerweise kann der dann Mac VTab machen oder wie das heißt.
Guck mal Leute die VM funktioniert. Die VM geht einfach. Calc Wait. Einfach einfach
geht einfach. Funktioniert einfach. Geht einfach. Easy. Ok. Nice. Dann kann ich das
jetzt ja wieder löschen und dann können wir die Home Assistant vorher machen. Vorher
muss ich mir übrigens auch. Vorher müssen wir uns noch überlegen wie es irgendwie gebacken
wird. Nee Leute Leute wir machen was anderes. Wir machen die Home Assistant VM aber vorher
installierst du ein Minimal Linux. Ich installiere mal ein Debian Minimal oder so was. Weil
ich will gucken. Ich will gucken was das Ding für eine Performance hat im Vergleich zum
Host. Das müssen wir ausprobieren. So ein Chain Law ist wieder da. Exzellent. Das müssen
wir gucken. Sys Bench. Wie ist das Sys Bench. Linux Benchmark. CPU. Sys Bench. Nein. Sys
Bench und. War das eine. Stress kann man auch machen ja. Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
ich Sys Bench meinte. Doch genau. Da siehst du nämlich wie schnell der ganze Kram ist.
Also installieren wir das erstmal auf dem Host. Dann Benchmarken wir mal CPU. Kotz das
Ding nicht rum wenn du mehr als eine Vm laufe lässt. Nö glaub ich nicht. Oh das geht
nicht mehr. Sys Bench. Sys Ach Minus Minus Test ist es jetzt. Minus Minus Test gleich
ne. Minus. Was zum. Was machst du jetzt hier verkehrt. Sys Bench. Test. CPU. Muss doch
funktionieren. Ach hier. Lump Threads. Zwei. Hä. Missing Required Argument. Wo ist das
Problem. Was hat er jetzt schon wieder verschmerze. Moment muss ich Test CPU dahinter machen.
Und Test CPU vielleicht. Ah exzellent exzellent. Ok ich kopiere das einfach von Distortion
und jetzt mal gucken. Hä was habe ich denn jetzt anders gemacht. Test gleich CPU. Ach
ich hab das Run vergessen kann das sein. Ach so. Hab kein Run gemacht. Da muss man
jetzt erstmal drauf kommen. So also Minimal Debian brauchen wir jetzt. Ne vorher muss
ich gucken das ich Netzwerk Zugriff auf die auf die bekomme. Install. Gibt es auf dem
Raspberry Pi. Ich mein ich könnte auch ne Bridge machen. Mach einfach ne Bridge und
gut ist. So also das ist die Geschwindigkeit von unserer CPU hier. Das müssen wir nachher
vergleichen mit der VM. Mal ne Frage Max wie stellst du Chromium in Dark Mode hier. Dark
Reader. Ja wir bridgeen wahrscheinlich die Netzwerk Karte direkt. Wie macht man das
jetzt aktuell unter Raspian. Also unter Ubuntu ist es ja Netplan. Das ist leider glücklicherweise
nicht mehr. Also Network. Network Interfaces. Ok das ist klassische Debian Geschichte. Interfaces
D. Ne. Ok wie macht man ne Bridge auf Raspberry Pi mit nem aktuellen Debian. Big Brain. Bridge
Debian. Raspberry Pi. ETH 0. Ja Briat ich will aber was was man automatisch hochfährt.
Ich will keine WLAN Bridge. Ich will mal normales Netzwerk Interface Bridgeen. Ja das
das. Die Idee bin ich auch schon gekomme. Nein nein nein ich brauch was was das automatisch
am Neustart macht. Ich mach das dann jedes mal von Hand. Normalerweise würdest du das
hier eintragen. Aber so wahrscheinlich nicht hier. Tja hab ich noch nicht gemacht. Und
ich will mein Netzwerk auch nicht kaputt machen. Kann ich einfach Mac VTab drauf bekommen das
wäre viel einfacher. Moment schauen wir mal. Was hab ich hier für Optionen. Wirt IO. Alter
warum kackt der Scheiß ab. Guck mal ein Wirt Manager ist mega instable. Ist das überhaupt
ein Wort. Also es ist extrem instable. Details. Virtual Networks. Bri. Wir Bri 0. Jetzt kann
man da eigentlich alles hinzufügen. Tests. Forward. Forward to physical network. Any
physical device. Mode Open. Ich hab keinen Plassen Chimmer was das macht wenn ich ehrlich
bin. Any physical device. ETH 0 ist kein physical device. Das wird doch im Leben nicht
funktionieren was ich hier mach. Das wird gar nicht funktionieren. Okay probieren wir
ob ich Netzwerk Connection bekomme. Einer vm jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht. So. Network.
Test. Was auch immer Open Network ist. Hypervisor Default. Ja okay. Ich glaube ich mach doch
ne Pritsch. Ja ja man muss die Network Interfaces machen aber ich hab die Bedenken dass der
Raspberry Pi irgendwo anders die Konfig hat weil es liegt da einfach nix rum. Okay wir
müssen erstmal die vm irgendwie ans Netzwerk bekommen. So ist das jetzt gestartet. Was
ist das. Was bin ich. Ist das EFI Boot oder was ist das hier. Boot. Nee wir booten von
der Netzwerkkarte. Was denn sonst. Oh jetzt hab ich es kaputt gemacht Leute. Broken vm.
Sack. Sack. Was hat das Ding für ein Problem. Musik. Musik vorbei. Frau Neue. Relaxing Nintendo
Vibe Music. Nee das ist mir. Ah das ist nice. Shutdown Guest. Okay. Yes. So. Yes. Enable
Bootmenu. Apply. Meine Settings. Next. So wir müssen jetzt erstmal rausfinden wie ich
ne ordentliche Netzwerk Pritsch und mit dem. Ist das. Wait. Wait. Stopp. Okay das Bootmenu
wird noch ein bisschen komplizierter das Ding zu einer Pritsch zu überreden. Müssen wir
mal schauen. Ja ja Pritsch Hotels das ist an sich total easy aber ich brauch was was
nach dem Neustart automatisch wieder hoch kommt. So start pxd. Ey wahrscheinlich kriegt er
keine Verbindung zur Außenwelt jetzt. Wird mich auch ganz stark wundern. Pritsch ne. Nee
geht nicht. Okay da müssen wir wirklich gucken. Alter warum kacken da Kram ab. Da müssen
wir wirklich gucken wie wir da ne Pritsch anlegen können. Auf nicht abkacken. Come on.
So ausschalten. Zack. Und den Scheiß wieder umstellen. Vielleicht geht es jetzt ja. Aber
wahrscheinlich nicht. Ne. Wait a minute. Warum konnte er das jetzt applyen. Warum konnte
er das jetzt. Vorhin hat er noch gesagt das geht nicht. Will er mich. Will er mich. Ich
glaub dass er mich bildet. Ah. Okay. Okay das wird nicht funktionen. Alles klar. Okay
Pritsch Raspberry Pi eth0. Interfaces also. Etc dhc dhcpd was dhcpd cdconf. Okay das
brauchen wir alles schon mal nicht. Das heißt wir machen jetzt einfach ne stink normale debian
interfaces debian interfaces bridge. Gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert. So bridge hotels
haben wir ja drauf. Pritsctl nee haben wir nicht. Brauchen wir auch nicht. Wir brauchen
das hier. Network interfaces alles klar. Wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich sperre ich mich jetzt erstmal
selbst aus. So wie ich mich kenne ich sperre mich jetzt wahrscheinlich erstmal selbst
aus. Und dann muss ich die micro sd karte hier wieder in kartenleser machen um das wieder
zu ändern. Etc network interfaces source directory ja ja mach hier mal einfach. Set paste. Falsche
Richtung falsche Richtung. Sollte das nicht ordentlich einrücken eigentlich. Loopback
brauchen wir nicht. ETH interface 1 manual bridge set up. Bridge ports eth0. Das sollte
doch eigentlich reichen oder. Bridge. Zerlieren wir das mal falls wir das brauchen. Ich weiss
wir können dem Ding auch hardcoded ne adresse geben. Probieren wir das mal aus. Ich glaube
das ist besser. Ich gebe dem Ding hardcoded ne adresse. Man weiß ja nie. Set paste. Also
gehen wir dem Ding. Also bridge 0. Static eth0 kommt nur in die ports. Was anderes brauchen
wir nicht. IP adresse 2. Was hat der aktuell. 2.128. So 2 passt. Gateway 2.1 ist glaube
ich. So also das müsste doch jetzt eigentlich funktionieren. System ctl und dann restart
network. Ich sperre mich jetzt garantiert aus leute ich sag es euch. Und wie ging das
ich hab das ewig nicht gemacht oder debian. Ist es networking. Networking restart. So
erstmal wie machen wir gucken wir ob das jetzt einfach abkackt. Nein. Achso Moment restart.
Networking. Networking. Kack wait hat es jetzt funktioniert. Nee. Nee hat nicht funktioniert.
Moment. Warte mal. Warte mal. Meine bridge ist nicht da ne. Nein nein warum soll ich
dhcp dhcp neu starten dafür. Muss die dhcp eher ausmachen. System ctl. Ging das scheiß
noch mal. Ich hab das 5 Jahre nicht mehr verwendet oder so. Meine Güte. Alter. Das
ist ja massive pains champ. Ein extrem massiver pains champ. Raspberry Pi. Hinweis. Jaja das
muss ich wahrscheinlich ausschalten. Und ja und was muss ich jetzt machen. Reboot ja
super. Ja das hab ich doch gerade gemacht. Ob ich das mit service mache ist doch eigentlich
egal. Was denn. If up. Nee das geht anders. Ich weiß dass es mit if down geht aber dann
sperre ich mich ja aus über ssh. Ja Service ist ein Swim Link auf System ctl glaube ich.
Und jetzt. Ja wenn das nicht funktioniert was machen wir denn jetzt. Reboot. So wahrscheinlich
habe ich mich jetzt ausgesperrt. Ich bin so dumm die bridge anzulegen auf dem Teil mit
den. Mit den standard tools. Ich hab das. Wie gesagt ich hab das 5 Jahre oder so nicht
mehr gemacht. Das ist gefährlich. Das sollte die auf gar keinen Fall machen über ssh.
Das sollte die nur machen über ssh wenn ihr es in dem team max ausführt oder so. Auf
gar keinen Fall einfach so. Ansonsten fliegt der raus und das ist. Ok ich hab mich irgendwie
ausgesperrt. Es funktioniert nicht. Es war klar. Es war klar dass es nicht funktioniert.
Ja. Wie hast du es sonst bei deine Ubuntu Server gemacht. Naja über netplan. Weil netplan
zwar sackt aber da weiß ich mittlerweile wie es geht. Außerdem hab ich für den keine
bridge. Ok ich hab mich ausgesperrt. Ich muss die micro SD gerade wieder rein machen.
Ich hab die. Ich beziehe nichts über dhcp ich hab hartcoded. Guck mal in meinen. Ok
ich muss die micro SD Karte rein machen. Guck mal aus. Wie kriege ich auf diesem Kackding
eine bridge angelegt mit eth0. Das dumme ist dass ich über eth0 eingeloggt bin und
ich sonst raus fliege. So erstmal die micro SD Karte wieder rein stöpseln. Jawoll. Wlan
machen. Ne das ist grad nicht so einfach. Könnte ich machen. Aber das ist grad nicht
keine so gute Idee. Wo ist er denn. Ne. Ist er. Ok. So jetzt muss ich erstmal die ganzen
Mist wieder entfernen dass ich mein Raspberry Pi starten kann. Mount. Stb. Stc ist es jetzt.
Da meint wegen da ist es jetzt stc. Wer da meint. So also etc network interfaces. Also
funktioniert schon mal nett was ich da gemacht hab. Das ist schon mal RIP. Klappt schon mal
überhaupt nicht. Kann ich wieder rausschmeißen. Wie nennt sich das forever workstation. Da
ist nichts drin. Sonst hätte ich es da drüber gemacht. Da ist nichts drin. Ich hab keine
Ahnung wie man sowas einstellt auf Raspberry Pi. Da ist nichts drin. Unmount. So sync. Bam.
So jetzt sollte er den Raspberry Pi zumindest wieder starten. Das ist schon mal ganz praktisch
schwer. Warum steckt man Mikro SD Karten immer falsch rum rein. Es wäre auch viel einfacher.
Wenn ich das Ding irgendwie auf den Raspberry Pi zum laufen bekommen würde zum Pritchen.
Ich brauche ja eigentlich gar keine Pritch. Ich will einfach nur vm ran bekommen. Brauche
ich denn ein Kernel Modul für. Warum verbraucht eine vm ever workstation eigentlich so viel
Speicherplatz. Die vm braucht genauso viel Speicherplatz wie du auf die Platte schreibst.
Das hatten wir doch drin stehen. Wir sind wieder on. Bin schon mal beruhigt. Wie macht
man eine fucking Netzwerk Pritch mit dem Raspberry Pi. Da muss es doch ein Guide für geben.
Warum willst du überhaupt vms auf Raspberry. Weil es geht. Und weil es eine praktische
Geschichte ist wenn man zum Beispiel seinen Home Assistant drauf laufen lassen will.
Raspberry Pi. Wir gucken jetzt an der Netzwerk Pritch. Da muss es doch einen Guide für geben.
Kann doch nicht sein. Ja meinetwegen als WLAN Pritch. Ethernet Pritch. Genau. Zeig her.
Die weiteren Einträge auf Doom. Gib mir einfach eine Zeile die ich da reinschreiben
kann. Mach das gleiche noch mal. Nee das wird nicht funktionieren. Ja das könnt ihr mir
auch anzeigen. Nein ich brauche einfach. Ein Guide. Gut das ist für WLAN das sagt.
Was zum. Ach du Scheiße was ist das. ETC System D Network. MonkaS. Über System D den
Kram zu konfigurieren ist ja noch schlimmer. Network D. Das ist richtig Monarch S. Default
Link. Alles klar. So. Du hast bei dir Via System D konfiguriert. Dann schick mal einfach
Link. Die machen das da über Netplan. Netplan haben die hier nicht.
Hast du schon mal was von Unraid gehört. Ja. Er paste mir mal ein Snippet wenn du was hast.
Keine Ahnung wie das aussehen muss. Das sind ja nur zwei Zeilen oder so. Die kannst du
denke ich auch mal im Chat posten ohne dass da was kaputt geht. Doch doch du hast den
Chat Manager aber nicht um deinen ETH 0 zu plötzchen. Das hier in Network Interfaces
sagt der Chat. Nee. Das hatte ich doch gerade das funktioniert. Chat guckt ihr zu. Genau
das hatte ich doch gerade in Network Interfaces drin. Das funktioniert nicht. Außerdem. Nee
ist richtig. Ist richtig. Oder hatte ich da irgendwas verkehrt drin. Ich habe eine billige
Forever Lizenz. Ich habe was vergessen. Ich vertraue dem Chat. Also. Ich mach das noch
mal. Ok. Danach mache ich das vom Twin Core. So. Also. Chat. Guck mal ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ich ich vertraue euch. Ich vertraue euch. Da heißt es halt Vm. Vm brrr ist auch ok.
So. Jetzt. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert. Ich habe das Auto vergessen.
Wirklich. Ja. Warum ist eigentlich standardmäßig die Maus in dem Vim an. Wer hat sich das
ausgedacht. Das ist ja muss der Anzeige ist raus. So wir starten mal ein Team Max. Jetzt
können wir tatsächlich mal. Wie habe ich das Ding jetzt genannt. Hier ist das Ding jetzt
Vm brrr 0. If ab Vm brrr 0. Tatsächlich. Moment. Jetzt ist. Sekunde. Jetzt habe ich
0. Aber auch noch oben. Du musst 0. Nicht hinzufügen. Ja. Wie soll das sonst funktionieren.
Wozu brauche ich eine Brücke. Wenn da mein Netzwerk Interface nicht dran hängt. Ich
glaube auch dass ich es lieber mit Reboot mache. Ich habe wir könnten. Wir könnten probieren.
Irgendwie. If down oder so. Komm. Scheiß drauf. Ich mach Reboot. Wahrscheinlich habe ich jetzt
wieder ausgesperrt. Das war alles umsonst. Ok Leute. Post Champen. Post Champ Time. 40
habe ich neu gebootet. Mal gucken was jetzt passiert. We are not vom Bridge Routen. Was.
MonkaS. Chat. Oh. Wir sind wieder am Start. Wir sind wieder am Start. Hat funktioniert.
Sehr gut. Bäm. Alles klar. Jetzt können wir weitermachen. Post Champ. Wirt Manager.
Jawoll. Demian. Vm. Und jetzt kann ich auch PXE booten. Pass auf. Huge PXE Boot kommt
jetzt. Netzwerk. Chat Device. Vm 0. Apply. Ja. Please. Apply. Start. Ha. Gibt es eine
Möglichkeit dass ich zum Beispiel 10 Temperatursensoren an meinen Raspberry Pi enthänge. Ja. Mit I2C
ist das kein Problem. So und macht er jetzt Netzwerkboot oder nicht? Er macht gar nichts.
Er post champt. Er post champt. Normalerweise sollte der eigentlich jetzt über. Da ist
er doch. Netboot. Jawoll. Funktioniert doch. Ach das ist kein Armkörnel den ich da drauf
hab. Der kann ja da drüber gar nicht netbooten. Das ist doch bestimmt nur in x86 only was
ich da hab. Richtiger Paynes Champ. Ne. Ja dann. Dann hänge ich da mal. Dann hänge
ich da mal Minimal Demian dran. Demian. Download. Netzwerk Installation Minimal CD. Genau.
So. Wo gibt's denn die zum Download? Torrent. OneKS. Ich will das doch nicht über Torrent
runterladen. Hier über HTTP, FTP runterladen. Official stable release. Ja. So ist gut. So.
64. Brauche ich da wahrscheinlich. Netinstall. Das Proma. Demian Netinstall. Da sehen wir
auch schon gleich wie schnell das Ding läuft oder nicht. By the way ich sollte das nicht
hier runterladen. Ich sollte das auch von Raspberry Pi runterladen. War lib lib lib
lib imagesEs muss das glaube ich hin so. faak. Jetzt können wir das ausprobieren. So
wir installieren jetzt ein Minimaldemian. Dann machen wir ein paar Benchmarks drauf.
Gucken wie das. потом rollen oder was. Sagt bloß jetzt ist kein DHCP gesetzt ne. Es ist
kein Default Gateway gesetzt. Wait a minute. Wobei doch müsste eigentlich ein default
Gateway gesetzt sein
Ist denn 2.1 überhaupt der richtige Default Gateway?
Ah, 2.50 ist der richtige Default Gateway.
Pain's Chamber, kein Wunder, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Lul.
Kann man hier noch ein DNS Server setzen?
Interfaces
Network, Interfaces, DNS. Geht das hier?
DNS Nameservers, jawoll. Bam.
Ey komm, gleich, wird gleich gegoogelt.
So, ich hoffe ich hab jetzt keinen Sündagsfehler drin, dann starte ich das nämlich mal neu.
Und dann sollte ich auch Verbindung haben.
So, Max FPS und all der Frösse sind schwul, Zitat 2011.
Naja, exzellent. Wen zitierst du da?
Ich hab übrigens auch gehört, dass Albert Einstein gesagt hat, Linux ist das beste Betriebssystem.
Ey, findest du Budgie als Linux Desktop?
Äh, hab ich noch nie verwendet, glaube.
Da sind wir wieder, SSH.
So, und jetzt können wir das ISO, glaube ich, runterladen.
VAR, LIP, LIPWIRT, IMAGES, WEGET.
Ah, jetzt haben wir die Idee, Bionet Installer am Start.
Gateway 2.50, why?
Frag mich das mal, hättest mich das mal vor 4 Jahren gefragt, da hab ich das eingestellt.
Jetzt weiß ich das nicht mehr.
Jetzt ist es einfach so, und es bleibt jetzt auch so, weil alles voreingestellt ist.
Cinnamon hab ich getestet, ist ganz nice, funktioniert in der VM aber nicht so gut.
Also der Wirtmanager hier ist wirklich lahm.
Wir können das ja gleich mal über SSH probieren, ob es dann besser funktioniert.
Also, jetzt müssen wir erstmal einstellen, dass die, okay, es verwendet ETH 0.
Und jetzt muss ich mal einstellen, dass der booted von dem CD, von einem CD-Laufwerk.
Hab ich hier ein CD-Laufwerk dran hängen?
Nee, oder?
Kein CD-Laufwerk dran hängen.
Wie, wie, wie Attachments?
Jetzt hier nochmal ein CD.
CD, Custom Storage, Debianet Install, Finish.
So.
Jaja, booted mal von Zata als erstes, please.
Das Zitat hat der Rollstuhl-Hater geschrieben, der Rollstuhl-Hater, der weiß es.
Der erkennt sich aus.
Der Beste, was macht der Rollstuhl-Hater eigentlich noch Videos?
Rollstuhl-Hater, wo ist der Rollstuhl-Hater?
Er war ein echter Hater, seht ihr mal.
Ein echter Hater.
Ich weiß, dass das Max Rolls ist.
ETF, das hat er schon oft genug im Chat geschrieben.
Kann das sein, dass er nicht bootet?
Das hab ich aber nicht ausge...
Moment, das ist auch die falsche Sache.
Okay, das Ding startet keine Debianet Install.
So.
But why? Warum bootet das nicht von der CD?
Boot Options.
Net Install...
Keine Ahnung, anscheinend gibt's das ja.
Stell mal auf IDE, das ist eine gute Idee.
Ah, okay.
Ja.
Warum machen wir das mal so probieren?
EFI auf BIOS, wir sind hier auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Da gibt's so spezielle Dinger, glaubt net.
EFI Firmware, doch, tatsächlich.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt startet.
Wenn nicht, ich geh noch mal in den Guide gleich rein, wenn der nicht startet.
Und mach das mal anhand von dem Guide, was der Typ da einstellt.
Warum will der immer...
Jetzt vielleicht?
Ich mein, da sollte ja eigentlich jetzt nur...
Ja, da sind wir, Leute.
Install.
Funktioniert alles.
So, jetzt können wir schon mal den ersten Eindruck bekommen, wie schnell das Ganze ungefähr läuft.
Weil so eine Debianet Install geht meistens relativ schnell.
Wow.
What the...
Das ist normal.
Oh, Leute, Grip.
Ging ja weit, ging ja echt weit.
Das ging ja wirklich, hat lange gebootet, das Ganze.
Nicht schlecht.
Okay.
Das war nix für den...
Oh, das hab ich jetzt net gesehen.
Aber ich hab ne...
Aber sollte doch eigentlich nicht sein.
Ich mein, ich hab da schon ne arm Netzwerkboot drinne.
Okay, wenn das nicht funktioniert, ich guck noch mal in den Guide rein, was der Typ schreibt.
Hä, das war Standardausgabe?
Nee, das war irgendein Panic.
Das ist gecrashed.
Okay, also was stellt der Typ hier ein?
Welches Alp...
Alpin, Alpine, wie spricht man das überhaupt aus?
Art...
Hab ich, hab ich.
Ja, ich bin auch vor 30 Minuten ausgeschrieben.
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, was da Sache ist.
War kein Panic?
Echt nicht?
Das sah für mich so nach nem Panic aus.
So.
Was stellt der da noch ein?
Nix, oder?
Der...
Ich mein, im Prinzip ist da auch nix.
Viel anderes eingestellt als bei mir.
Ja, ich glaub, das Ding ist...
Ich glaub, das Ding ist RIP.
Aber dann sollte, aber...
Also, wenn's die falsche Architektur wäre,
würde ja auch schon mal kein Crap starten.
Wir gucken einfach noch mal, wir gucken einfach noch mal.
Im Prinzip, im Prinzip ist ja...
Mehrfach Versuchen oftmals von Erfolg gekrönt.
Pause-Champ?
Also, wenn das kein Panic ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Das war nett.
Das ist doch ein Panic, oder?
Meint wirklich jemand, da geht's jetzt noch weiter?
Unable to handle kernel-paging-request.
Okay, das klingt nicht gut.
RIP, da geht nix weiter.
Gut, das funktioniert nicht.
So.
Wie kriegen...
Wie konnte man da jetzt noch mal umstellen?
Ich mein, das Ding
benutzt ja aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Meint es, dass es, ähm...
UEFI verwendet, aber ich glaube,
das ist einfach nur Bullshit-Anzeige, ne?
Raspberry Pi, Linux?
Das ist was anderes.
Das, was ich da hab, liegt garantiert am KVM.
Probier mal das L-Pi-Linux, das machen wir.
Wisst ihr was, Leute?
Ich lösche das jetzt noch mal.
Ich lösche das noch mal.
Und, äh, ich mach das mal wirklich,
was der Typ hier, was der Typ im Tutorial macht.
Einfach nur mal zu gucken, ob der Principle was startet.
Warum will man KVM auf Raspberry Pi machen?
Weil's nice ist.
Massive nice ist.
So, ich will aber...
Ich will ehrlich gesagt, brauche ich nur irgendwas
mit einem Sysbench oder irgendwas drauf,
wo ich einfach mal ausprobieren kann,
wie schnell der Kram in der KVM überhaupt ist.
Also, wo lädt er sich das jetzt denn überhaupt runter hier?
AlpinLinux.
Wo hat er's denn?
Wo gibt's denn den Kram überhaupt?
Hier, alpinlinux.org.
Alpinlinux.org, download.
So, und was nimmt der Typ jetzt hier?
Äh...
VirtualArch64.
SlimDownKernOptimals für VirtualArch64.
Okay, das da brauchen wir jetzt.
Alles klar.
Weget.
So.
Jetzt haben wir's.
So, und nu?
Ja, ja.
Okay, der macht nichts Besonderes,
außer das Image auszuwählen,
oder?
Wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Also, er sagt New, KVM.
Local Install CD-ROM.
Select.
Alpine.
Detect Automatically hat er gemacht.
Non-Detected.
Okay.
Ach nee, das soll man wegmachen.
Alpin38.
Okay.
Alpin...
Okay, 38.
Forward.
So, Memory.
Leute, ich lass es mal so.
Ich lass es mal so.
Mehr CPU und RAM kann ich dem Ding immer noch geben.
4G sollte
erst mal reichen. Server ist auch
egal. Network.
Forward.
Network Selection.
ETH0.
Finish.
So, mal gucken.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt startet.
Wie
hatte man unter Alpine nochmal was installiert?
APK oder so, ne?
APK.
APK Install. Da gibt's bestimmt auch einen Suspension
für...
...
Okay, es startet.
Exquisite.
Booting. Booting klingt schon mal gut.
Und es gibt noch keinen Panic oder so was.
APK ist
Android.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, warum die bei Alpine
dann APK genommen haben.
Hängt das Stream?
Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, das liegt
an dir. Stats.
Ja, wir hatten 26 Drop Frames
von 3 Millionen
oder so.
Booting.
Boah, 100%
CPU-Auslastung.
Das ist ja lahmes Fax. So ein
Alpine Linux ist normalerweise
das Ding ist normalerweise
gebootet in, frag mich nicht,
2 Sekunden oder so.
After a few seconds. Nope.
Ich sehe after a few seconds
da gar nichts.
Der booted 100% CPU-lastig
booted da gerade.
Ich hab so das doofe
Gefühl, so richtig gut
funktioniert das nicht.
Ähm, ich starte
den Wirtmanager mal über
mein Hostsystem
und dann gehen wir da drüber drauf.
Ist glaube ich sinnvoller.
Kann ich mich ja dann
attachen.
Wirtmanager.
Okay, ah
Fuck, welcher Wirtmanager ist jetzt was?
Ich bin OMG
Wirtmanager, okay.
Connect
Add Connection
Was? LXC?
Nee, nee, nee.
QEMO, KVM. Boot
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Auf
Wait, wait a minute.
Ah nee, Hostname. Lul.
Ähm,
ich muss mich da connecten können
über
Keys, ne?
Okay.
Copy ID.
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Kann ich mich jetzt als
Root verbinden? Jawoll.
Okay, Root, 1, 2, 1, 6, 8, 2,
1, 2, 8.
Ist glaube ich die IP vom Raspberry Pi.
Autoconnect.
Okay, das
funktioniert. Jetzt kann ich den Mist hier
zumachen.
Kann ich es lokal ausführen, dürfte
ein bisschen schneller gehen.
Okay, das ist RIP.
Also, das Ding bootet nicht.
Das hängt
beim Booten.
Das war einfach gar nichts.
Wir machen nochmal Stopp.
Ich geb dem Ding gerade nochmal zum Test ein bisschen
mehr RAM. Ich kann mir aber ehrlich gesagt nicht
vorstellen,
dass das damit irgendwas zu tun hat.
Der hat eher Probleme.
Der dürfte wahrscheinlich eher Probleme haben,
wenn ich ihm mehr CPU Kerne gebe.
Guck dir mal die CPU-Config an.
Hat der Typ hier im Tutorial irgendwas da dran gedreht
an der CPU-Config? Ne, oder?
Aber wer weiß,
ob das Tutorial sinnvoll ist.
Ich würde jetzt sagen,
ja, kann man
so machen.
Ich starte es einfach nochmal neu.
Mach mal ein Hardtop auf
auf den Pi.
Der ist einfach am Anschlag
jetzt gleich.
Bam!
Wait, wait a minute.
Hat er gar nicht mehr gebootet?
Ah, so CD-ROM muss wieder
sein.
Mein Gott, manchmal ist das Handling
manchmal ist das Handling schon ein bisschen
painz-champig, ne?
Vor allem, das laggt
übelst rum.
Ich habe am Anfang nicht
Chrome installiert.
Ach, daran liegt das.
Jetzt verstehe ich es.
Ich hätte wieder im Tutorial Chrome installieren müssen.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Copy-Host-Info.
Ich glaube, das bringt alles nichts.
Okay, so, jetzt sollte er von der CD
wieder starten.
Was?
Alter, wo ist dein Problem?
Warum startest du nicht von der CD?
Oder macht das jetzt vielleicht?
Ah, macht er. Excellent. Enter.
Was ist das hier eigentlich
für komisches...
Der hängt mit einem CPU-Kern komplett am Anschlag.
Nee, der hängt mit zwei CPU-Kern
komplett am Anschlag. Da bootet nichts,
Leute. Da bootet echt gar nichts.
Also, ich würde sagen, KVM auf
Raspberry Pi ist vielleicht noch nicht so wahnsinnig
ausgereift.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es funktioniert.
Jetzt steht auch gar nichts mehr von
Booting da, by the way.
Booting da.
Okay, wir gucken mal.
Vielleicht gibt es noch irgendeine andere Anleitung.
Naja, soweit komme ich noch nicht mal.
Soweit komme ich noch nicht mal.
Okay, wir gucken mal.
Ich habe das schon schon mal gehabt.
so ich mein viel mehr als der dude kann ich jetzt ja hier nicht machen ich kann
es noch mal stoppen und kann auch noch mal ein cp und noch mal ein cpu rein
reinschmeißen falls er probleme hat mit mehr im nächsten stream noch mal
ubuntu server test ich glaube das macht keinen unterschied ich glaube das
liegt eher daran dass es noch äußerst experimental ist
ich mein immerhin fängt da schon mal an zu booten
guck mal da steht sogar booting da also mit zwei cpu können marker schon mal gar nicht
das kann man tatsächlich mal gucken
sieht das jetzt so wahnsinnig schlimm aus doch was hat er hier dass er irgendwie
dass er nicht das cannot detect host cpu model muss er ja auch nicht es x lief
ganz ok also ich würde nicht sagen dass es wahnsinnig wahnsinnig flutscht so
also mal weitere geilen skunk kvm pie vor das ist ein anderer ist ein anderer
guide das ist der guide für fedora aber da macht er doch im prinzip genau das
gleich oder macht er in dem fedora guide irgendwas anders
host ist 32 spinn und gast ist 64 spit was ne beides es ist beides 64 spit
host ist 64 spit und gast ist 64 spit ja ja ist es guck da
bäm das war das war das erste was ich gemacht habe
ansonsten kann sie kvm gar nicht verwenden
ja im prinzip machen die dudes hier exakt das gleiche wie ich auch ohne
irgendwie install ohne irgendwelche spezial dinger
was benutzt er hier für den ubuntu server zum anlegen des systems ok ich
mache auch noch mal ubuntu 24 arm das können wir noch mal probieren ich meine
scheiß drauf ubuntu surfer vor armen jawohl copy link kann man auch noch mal
probieren der boot nicht ganze ganze knicken war lip lip wird aber ich weiß
wenn schon alt bei nicht bootet dann wird wahrscheinlich ubuntu erst recht
entboten aber gucken wir mal schon spät ja gleich 22 uhr dann ist vorbei und das
kann man wieder löschen
hier wir machen eine vm noch mit dem ubuntu image und gucken ob es dann
funktioniert die machen aber alle kein netzwerk
der der kommt ja noch nicht mal bis zum netzwerk
ich habe doch hier schon journal gerade geguckt das ist doch hier die
journal ausgabe da so mit dem ubuntu den probieren was immer stand dort 2
gigabyte ram in dem tutorial ja für ubuntu 2 gigabyte ram kannst du nach
rechts rollen nee das müsste ich gleich noch mal machen warte mal mal in less
rein kann ich auch scrollen so cannot this function is not supported by
connecting driver cannot detect host cpu model hallo ich glaube das ist ja komm
ich leg jetzt noch mal ubuntu surfer an und dann gucken wir ob das ob das irgendwie
booted ich meine hier kann ich auch noch zeug einstellen aber ich meine was
was soll ich anderes einstellen als das wofür ich ne
und mit bei architektur options machen die auch gar nix am anfang
fallen was sollte was sollte ich da noch einstellen
machen wir bei cpu detect from host das können wir dann das können wir dann
machen wenn es angelegt habe ja ok local install media install media
jubanto server wie not detectet
jetzt eigentlich erwartet dass er das attacken detectet
nee das ist 60g sd karte ja wunderbar gib ihm alles wir machen
vielleicht 2048 und mal eine cpu falls das ding probleme hat 25g als man
nicht übertreibe 10g reicht next wobei ich kann ihm durchaus 25g geben das
wächst ja nur wenn es sachen brauchen network selection ich lasse es mal auf
nutt vielleicht kommt kommt da sonst durcheinander
erst network starten mit temple os wäre das nicht passiert das ist richtig
temple es wäre wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal installiert gegangen auf dem
ding postchamp postchamp macht er irgendwas was
ok dann war mal 2047 mb ram 2048 mb ram ist zu viel
alright next
ich weiß auch nicht wie man so oft die sich auf warum man sich auf diese zahl
festgelegt hat
ok so bunt du jubanto gib alles
ok ich drücke ich drücke mal enter na hallo
serielle konsole das ist ja kein problem solang das boot ist mir das alles recht
kann wahrscheinlich keine ordentliche grafische ausgabe
no video mode aktiviert ja das ok ok da hängt wird aber 100 prozent und macht
halt mal wieder nix
das function ist noch zu ported ja ok wir können tatsächlich die cpu mal
überschreiben oh er macht was
er macht dinger
fail to check link status ist mir doch egal huge high speed boot
man erkennt jetzt leider nicht ob der weiter booted ob der jetzt irgendwas
macht
ja was auch immer der mit pc e-port in pc express port hat kein schimmer
wir googeln da jetzt mal kurz danach
der zeit lasse ich ihn weiter booten vielleicht passiert noch irgendwas also
leute was ich heute im discord geschrieben habe nehme ich zurück ist
glaube ich doch keine so gute idee vm auf raspberry pi laufen zu lassen
kubernetes virtualisiert ich habe halt ganz andere probleme
das war ok ja also anscheinend ist es nicht schlimm dass man diese ausgaben
bekommt ok vergehen leute ganz knicken das auch voll knicken da tut sich nix
tut sich gar nichts wir gucken uns noch mal die cpu konfig kurz an also da muss
vorher wahrscheinlich ausmachen
kann ich irgendwie eine grafische ausgabe noch ordentlich hinzufügen
graphics
ich glaube nicht dass das was bringt oder vc sauber bringt es was dass er
sich dann besser connecten kann
oh ist kaputt gemacht kann er sich jetzt verfahren zähler drauf
connecten uns funktioniert besser schauen wir mal ok cpu konfig copy
haus cpu konfig na ob das ob das geht
hier starten
post camp ok unsupport konfiguration ist auch support ok also was was was nehmen
wir da jetzt wegen irgendwelche huge brain vorschläge also das war glaube
ich die fall gerade
ich würde auch sein dass das passt
tja funst nicht so gut wie ich mir vorgestellt habe vielleicht
ich glaube wir haben eine grafische ausgabe kann das sein
ne da checkt es bestimmt wieder nicht der schalt jetzt schon wieder auf konsolenausgabe um muss er jetzt schon wieder das
problem guten alter ich habe die boot options umgestellt
nerven wir nicht rum jess
ich habe gesagt jess medias select ubuntu force off dann mache ich danach noch mal an
starte das verdammte spiel genau apply
vielleicht können wir auch einfach was ist eigentlich für eine cpu drinne im
raspberry pie ist das ein a72 oh what the fuck das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich mal also
der da eigentlich dann ja ja jetzt jetzt jetzt so macht er jetzt was jaja so weit so weit so gut
also ich möchte da reinklicken okay leute ich kann noch nicht mal ich ich darf noch nicht mal
noch nicht mal hoch und runter machen mit der tastatur hier gerade wir lassen
es jetzt einfach mal timeout noch gucken was passiert
ne vergiss es jetzt ist er will display dass ich nicht macht die grafik ausgabe wieder weg jetzt
sehe ich nix doch ich habe vnc angemacht aber anscheinend mag der beim booten kein vnc mehr
sondern macht wieder aus ne leute das klappt das funktioniert nicht keine chance vnc wieder raus
wieso eigentlich kvm auf raspberry pie weil es geil wäre wenn es funktioniert aber es funktioniert
nicht wirklich gut vielleicht probiere ich das nächste mal noch mal auf dem fedora aus aber ich
habe so die die vermutung das wird uns nicht glücklich machen aber das wird das wird ja
schon nicht am vnc liegen oder nicht ja ne vergiss es leute das hat das hat keinen sinn ich lasse
jetzt noch mal durchlaufen vielleicht mag er jetzt aus irgendwelchen gründen vielleicht
probiere ich das nächste mal wirklich mit einem fedora aus oder mit ubuntu server vielleicht ist
das unter respire noch zu experimental also esx hatten wir schon mal ausprobiert esx ging
erstaunlicherweise relativ gut aber ist schon mal cool zu sehen als kvm prinzipiell drauf läuft
und startet aber dann halt abscheißt ja auf der anderen seite aber selbst wenn man das ich mich
hätte halt mich hätte wirklich unglaublich interessiert wie die performance ist in der
vm versus host auf normaler hardware ist es ja mittlerweile so dass du cpu technisch eigentlich
so gut wie keine performance unterschiede mehr hast zwischen zwischen vm und und host cpu technisch
das macht ja quasi was weiß ich wenn es ein prozent ist dann ist es viel aus ok der hat
keinen bock ne leute ripp vergiss vielleicht probiert es nix mit fedora aus macht sie das mal
aus wird beim power off denn ihr wisst was jetzt ist es ist 22 uhr und ihr wisst was um 22 uhr
passiert ist der frasier an frasier genau das passiert um 22 uhr
gibt es heute deutsche pool streams das ist eine gute frage aber heute ist es nicht so sehr
nach pool streams wir hausen aber es gibt mal jemanden ich den ich hausen kann massif ja ihn
hausen wir jetzt gucke ich auch immer die videos excellent content aber hausen weiß
ich was er macht macht er denn er macht mein browser hängt twitch den hausen wir jetzt
alles klar rate rate shadow legends heute nice aus stream hat leider nicht so funktioniert wie
ich mir das ganze vorgestellt habe wir sehen uns macht es gut bis morgen zu